hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to stop me
this sounds totally ridiculous a singing
rooster dresses up like Elvis shop well
if you can't even make it that far then
you're gonna have a real hard time with
down below strangest of animated
creations and that's saying a lot right
director Don Bluth was by far one of the
greatest animation gods who ever lived
in the eighties in the 90s I think he
left his brain at the foobar convention
because he turned out some very strange
very mediocre material the good stuff
seemed to end with all dogs go to heaven
and the bad stuff seemed to begin with
rock it's strange it's nonsensical it's
kind of like a bedtime story afraid by
Andy Warhol so why is this will be such
a mother clucking mess take a look and
decide for yourself the film begins in
outer space as a narrators voice comes
in two fatally attempt to tell the story
once upon a time the Sun came up imagine
for a moment if instead of rising up
like this she took a look around and
decided to go back to sleep
let me tell you all about and let me
warn you I've been drinking extensively
okay that Suman was a little too extreme
I could practically see a digestive
system
so as the movie begins you kind of can't
really believe what you're watching I
mean these look like cartoons from the
30s where everything has a face everyone
seems to be bouncing and singing what
did they make this movie for kids or
something still no excuse so I know what
you're probably thinking what current
washed-up singer did they rope into do
the voice of this personality deprived
character I'm gonna say Garth Brooks
yeah Glen Campbell so close laughs a
tune what you doing I'm trying to tie
these doggone shoes again it's probably
not best to tell you that this is the
highlight of the movie is it so all the
animals on the farm had their own
special job to do when a Rooster's job
is to crow so he can bring up the son
what's the name of the rooster you might
be wondering well I'm sure it's
something cutesy like lucky or feathers
or Chanticleer okay so they live on very
pretentious farm what do you like army
but one morning Chanticleer forgets to
chrome and yet the Sun still comes up so
the animals were check Shanta Claire and
toss him out of the farm which makes
things very happy for the villains
simply known as the Grand Duke of owls
what the hell oh okay I guess the story
was just a book a mother was reading to
her kid fair enough
his name is headland of course she
didn't look quite like this when I first
met my dad who's telling the story the
narrator the mother that's a really bad
sign we have two people fighting over
who's narrating the movie and so the
little boy looked out from his window
and then he never not a narrator stepped
in to tell the story who's telling this
story anyway well I thought I you
couldn't read your way out of an
alphabet hey them's fightin words
come over here you meat sack Oh
all rinsed so it turns out the little
boy is named Edmund and he's concerned
because the rain is picking up and
flooding the farm to his parents work on
I want to help well then pray for the
rain to stop
now our asking God for anything he still
owes me an Xbox so the parents go
outside as apparently the farm is being
attacked by the biggest storm of the
century turn the truck she'll be okay
laughs it's already here that Christmas
you moron Santa Claus only comes at
Christmas no he was calling Chanticleer
for help even though he's just a
fictional character in a book that
doesn't stop the Duke of elves from
breaking the laws of reality as he
crashes into the house to intimidate our
little hero yeah I've called him spoil
the surprise Oh overstream head Oh No
tell me that I wasn't voiced by
Christopher Plummer the Duke is going to
eat you
oh god what some people will do for a
paycheck he kind of thought this was a
good movie nobody caught up he must have
been under contract or something that's
the only excuse in fact I could just
imagine you're trying to sneak away from
this movie I hear they're going to
announce the casting for reviewing today
by the time you've made the announcement
we'll be over the border trouble with
your car mr. Plummer yes as a matter of
fact we couldn't get it started surely
you've heard that the studio wants you
to provide the voice for the owl and the
latest family romp rock-a-doodle I'm
afraid that's going to be quite possible
now mr. Plummer surely you don't think
you can defend yourself against the
awesome power of Studio funded lawyers
no man has ever survived their verbal
slaughter so I take it you'll change
your mind about the role yeah excellent
my men will escort you to the recording
studio el escort will be necessary I
insist we wouldn't want you to get lost
on your way over
would we he'll now if you'll excuse me
I'm off to get a pagoda for good burger
ok back to the story so the Duke of owls
in front of our little hero explains his
evil plan
but you see we creatures of the night
have worked very hard to make absolutely
sure that that bird does not return and
besides I positively loo my god are you
still talking so the owl turns him into
a kid because he claims they're easier
to kill but I think it's because they're
easier to draw as he turns to the rest
of the room into a fully animated
backdrop I guess I will see better in
watercolors but then the animals from
the book also come in to save little
Emma as it turns out the only thing that
can scare the Duke away is light that
must have my bright light syndrome but
the gremlin Stan what do you say kid
you're a little too young to know what
that word meet I'm an adult and I'm
still not exactly sure what it means nor
do I wish to find out so a bunch of
other animals come in to tell Emma that
they're also looking for Chanticleer why
because it turns out his crowing did
bring the Sun up and thus they need him
back for the Sun to return we gotta find
Chandi and apologize but if that's the
case why did it rise without on that one
time oh shit clear but he doesn't come
back alone this fellow ever shine again
uh hello uh why did it rise without him
that one time the story is true you all
left him and he went away
why did rise without him at one time
you're right son we done wrong and
that's why we're searching for the SID
why did I rise up you know fuck forget
I'm gonna make up my own reason God got
bored wanna fuck around the Roosters so
I play yo-yo with the Sun there I'm hey
let's see how us they're gonna confuse
me so the gang all decides to go to the
city because apparently there's a city
right across at the farm to find
Chanticleer meanwhile we see the duke
acting as the Phantom of the owl prop as
he tells his henchmen to find the
captain
actually no I tell a lie he doesn't talk
about it
he sings about it we hate the Sun that
much we go wow wow I can where they tell
from the first lyrics that this song is
gonna suck
that's incredible you want to try in
order to be that half we hate the song
head to toe let him crowd so the animals
float down the river if they encounter
many horrible disastrous obstacles in
their way like my god we'll hit that
eventually so the henchmen found the
animals and tried to attack but Edmond
sticks to his guns by doing what he
knows best shouting the words oh no my
way to negative vocabularies limited so
the animals escape and finally make it
to the city the Owls have returned to
tell the dude the bad news yo embrace
him that's not an adequate right oh yes
I forgot to mention that the dupes
breath contains magical powers you know
what this is this is the animated
version of Mad Libs
it makes just about as much sense so our
main hero gets turned into a animal yeah
okay he's transformed by the villains no
breath oh right they have to travel to
the city to find an animal rooster okay
who makes the Sun rise by her
yes Wow doesn't that sound ridiculous
imagine they made a movie based on that
nonsense it'd be stupid
so they search all throughout the city
for Chanticleer which is also populated
by animals well now how does that make
sense I mean do the parents when they
need farming supplies just drive to the
city filled with cartoon animals well
thank you mister big this frying pan
will really help us out with we're
cooking up some bacon that know how
about them buyers the team not the
people that own the hardware store down
the street there's also this weird
running joke about how the dog doesn't
know how to tie your shoes
no but you ever out code for the first
time it's over allowed undo and flew no
kid that's not how you act for the
hundredth time emote connect and be
credible finally they find Chanticleer
as he nominates is living as a
world-famous rooster Elvis impersonator
is a mirror all these characters and I
like sports teams mascot rejects well
you're the number one chicken this is
chicken coop a one character named
Goldie looks on Chanticleers Fame and
can't help but feel a tad jealous Oh
Goldie what you not bother me with this
right now
you gotta belong in two minutes but I'm
too good for the chorus what's he got
that I ain't got
well penis four stars so the game tries
to talk to Chanticleer but is pushed
aside by a team of bodyguard
it comes out you all over the place
bounce bounce bounce ah
you know good God you can make a song
about anything can't you I'm talking I'm
talking I'm drinking my coffee and then
I'm going to sleep meanwhile back to the
farm the floods getting worse as Edmund
calls up to see how the pink rabbit and
mouse are doing ah this is a strange
world of randomness isn't it no great oh
I'm going to waste all the minutes
moolah what about right Barry all right
your family they left this movie hours
ago then your stinking weather to see
one by number you have dialed is no
longer in service
oh no God just by the way the walkie I
can tell they're going to sing twiddly
deep 20k no song that begins with the
lyric tweedily-dee is going to be good
go back and try again so they try to get
a note Chanticleer this time disguising
themselves as penguin so they don't get
spotted hey what are you doing a little
fella from parents corner taking a
boarding school so they get the notes as
Chanticleer but it's distracted by the
love of his feathery life goalie she
says her name is Goldie
Hey look at that she kissed him on the
pecker neck see so goalie seduces
Chanticleer as they make sweet horribly
written music together I think we've
lost them or do you mean I love the fact
that a song is so bad that even the
movie is trying to ignore it it's like
they're ashamed that they made a musical
like I champagne so the game is captured
by the Battletoads here and tied up in
one of the trailers aha take that grill
but one of the owl henchmen still wants
to destroy her as he breaks into the
trailer and
I went what happened I don't know
somehow they escaped and if that's going
on Chanticleer finally discovers the
note as he rides off on a motorcycle to
save his friends oh I've killed them
ninja he's not dead untie me he's not
dead
and tell me so the catcher is partaken
what looks like been Ferraz the bad guys
are close behind you know this movie
provides many ample opportunities for
them to die why don't they just go with
it
what the hell was that is the movie
flashing before his eyes or rather in
his eyes and then we're in his brain
with all these characters I need Oh
piglet alligator moment please
so after that strange slip of
consciousness and then since the mouse
and they escaped the bad guys as we jump
back to the farm where we see the other
animals have run out of batteries in
their flashlights Oh
Vijay's balance aha
do they really have to sing everything
just because it's a musical doesn't mean
you have to sing you can just quietly
shut the fuck up I would prefer that but
thank God our heroes arrive to put that
Albarn choir in its place this is enmund
it's over for you this is Amen it's all
about for you god this kid makes Jake
Lloyd look like Haley Joel Osment so
they tried to get Chanticleer to crow
but he's sadly out of practice are you
by any chance coming in trouble with
wall thread don't give up Shanta Claire
put that belching Jim Carrey in his
place but the Duke uses his magic bread
to make things more difficult how do you
get magic breath anyway did he just
drink a cocktail of blended fairies and
Smurfs I mean how does that work
to make things worse he strangles Edmund
and transforms himself into a giant
tornado the Chanticleer finally gets his
voice back and crows like he's never
crude before
God hears you Chanteclair I didn't need
to put the rotation of the planets out
of order hope it was just fucking with
you and for some reason the Sun
transforms the evil dukkha vowels into
Cartman from South Park great movie and
a good hit me nananana screw this movie
him so what direction was fairytale
would be complete without the ultimate
cliche and Men turns into a real boy he
was a little boy he was such a bad actor
I couldn't tell and just to make it even
more insulting it turns out that the
whole thing was just a dream yep
everything about that chaotic little
trip was all in Edmonds head why does
that not surprise me
Edmund Chanteclair is just a storybook
those characters are on a make-believe
now come on let's get them on
look I'm not it's awesome I did the one
any would happen to I'd say this ending
was just working off the Wizard of Oz
but it is it's directly stealing from it
right down to everything becoming brown
and white does this movie have any shame
and then just to give us the ultimate of
non sequiturs Kakadu one why not hey why
no hey one's cock okay is this a dream
or did the kid get into the vicodin
again I mean this makes no sense
wow they turn me into a crybaby you
screen effect and does the movie
actually end not really it just kind of
stops
it's like whoops we forgot to make sense
of anything oh well it gives a gift why
for a few hours didn't exits do left
this was weird it was just weird it was
good it was bad okay it was bad but it
was mostly odd it's Santa's he's such a
great animator deprived himself of his
own talent
this movie is literally like they just
made up the story as they went and that
is
very rarely a good sign and I don't know
about you but quite frankly I'm getting
praised you are good at this game
Island establisher Critic I remember it
so you don't have to stir and I'll be
loose with you